okay this might be the most impressive
Tech demo I've ever seen it's also one
of the hardest to explain on video but
I'm gonna try so there's a thing called
Google projects Starline you might have
heard of it might have not but Google
has showed a few video examples of this
live super immersive like 3D video
calling Booth where you sit down in
front of it and on the other side
someone else sits down and through the
power of the internet it looks like an
extremely realistic version of them is
actually in front of you it's not just a
normal video call but it's not a
hologram it's just it's something
different either way we got the first
look at it at Google I O A couple of
years ago they showed this clip in the
keynote and nobody got to record it
nobody even got to try it but now
they're back with a better looking more
compact more simplified version
and I got to try it and record it now
just as a warning this first clip it
doesn't actually do it justice because
the effect does not translate very well
on camera we'll get to that but I was
lucky enough to get my first reaction to
this my actual first time seeing it on
camera
all right let's
see
project start line
oh wow oh hey how are you great okay
welcome to Starline
thank you this is right yeah it's a lot
more
yeah you and I just saw each other right
outside but we're in two different rooms
and we want to make it feel like we left
that space and we came back together in
uh virtual space it feels like we're
completely in the same spot it really
looks like I can actually uh it looks
like you could drop something on this
table right here yeah yeah I've got a
little apple over here so let me show
you that too so you know you and I are
in the same room do you want me to pass
this over into your space too it looks
like you can do it thank you
we're meant to feel like this room is
just one room instead of two separate
locations it could be anywhere in the
world so this is uh something we think
is the glimpse of what communication
could look like in the next few years
that's incredible okay yeah I gotta
learn more about this okay so what
exactly is happening here so I'm sitting
in front of the new Starline Booth is
what I call it now the first star line
they ever made was much bigger they had
these like full room setups essentially
with a bench and computers the display
but also a bunch of cameras and depth
sensors placed around you this new one
feels actually much more refined it
looks much simpler and it kind of feels
like a reasonable product it's a 65-inch
display on a stand with a smaller
barrier over the bottom bezel and then
there are actually some lights on the
back that point at the wall behind the
display that serve as a key light for me
the person on the call and then there
are no more depth sensors it's just a
tidy array of color cameras and micro
phones and speakers so that's at the top
the left and the right and they use AI
to create a depth map of me and the room
I'm in and then the magic of this is
twofold It's the display and the
Computing happening so the display the
part giving you the actually impressive
immersive 3D depth effect but then also
all the Computing happening to turn me
the person on the video call and the
person on the other side into this
realistic 3D model just with the camera
information that you can actually look
around with head tracking now clearly
this doesn't translate well on camera
which is why Google has understandably
been super protective over anyone trying
it even or or getting any photos or
videos of it because it just won't look
right but I was able to convince Google
to let me try something you see
basically once you first sit down in the
project Starline Booth this system has
to identify where your face is and then
you can move around and look at stuff
with head and body tracking and of
course that's not going to work if you
just put a camera in there but if you do
show it a face and a camera at the same
time like say maybe a cardboard face
where you can stick a camera lens
somehow through that cardboard face
then it would track and you could ah see
what I'm talking about check this out
so what you're seeing right now is as if
you were on a video call with me in the
newest version of Google Starline this
is the first time anyone outside of
Google has seen the sort of
visualization which is super cool so it
feel pretty reasonable right now right I
can hold up an object you can see the
colors and the shapes and the lighting
and textures on it and this is all
information compiled from the array of
cameras around me and the depth
information comes from these regular
cameras and that's all quite cool
but as you start moving around
that's when it starts getting a little
more interesting because I can hold
things out and you start to create this
Parallax effect with the head tracking
where you can start to literally look
around and inspect the object and look
underneath things as if you're literally
in the room with me it's super
convincing to the actual eye when you
see it on this screen even the
background behind me is not real it's
being composited in but I'm casting a
shadow on it and that's being rendered
in real time too it's a lot we can even
flip a switch to show a sort of a
topographical map of specifically the
depth information coming from these
cameras so again no depth cameras
specifically being used here but the
array of color cameras has all this
depth information being mapped and
that's what all the information from the
color cameras is being sort of projected
onto there's a lot of processing
Happening Here
so it all comes together to form this
really impressive
real-time I mean I use the word
immersion very lightly usually but I
will I want to stress that it's very
immersive when you actually get to use
it so hopefully this helps you visualize
so that is pretty cool but even that
doesn't translate perfectly because the
feeling of depth actually comes from the
distance between your eyes so a camera
lens is one eye but if you've ever tried
to catch something with one eye closed
you know that humans perceive depth by
the difference between what you see with
your left eye and what you see with your
right eye your brain stitches them
together and figures out depth that way
so even that demo doesn't quite get the
full realisticness of what I saw on
camera but it's pretty close the lights
will display in Project Starline is
literally showing a different image to
my left eye and to my right eye so
taking advantage of that biological fact
and then letting me actually compute
depth on the Fly while doing all the
head tracking in real time it's actually
kind of crazy like if you've ever seen
3D glasses you know how when you go see
a 3D movie like one of the eyes is blue
one of the eyes is red that's literally
because your left eye will see something
map for that and you're right I will see
something that for that and that's how
it creates the depth effect
but this is way better than a 3D movie
it's so much smoother and the head
tracking and everything that goes with
it and it's it's so good but then the
craziest part the the most impressive
part is the Computing that's happening
which is rendering the people using
Starline in real time into these 3D
models so this is not like the metaverse
thing or the VR headset tracks face
movement and then you can have a eye
contact face-to-face conversation with
someone's Cartoon Avatar but no no this
is this is taking the actual Imaging the
lighting the the way you actually look
what you're actually wearing and
rendering that out in real time in 3D
space and making it look like I'm
talking to them through a window it's
kind of amazing the eye contact is so
one-to-one real looking and it really
just comes from the fact that I'm
sitting here looking forward and the
person on the other side is also looking
forward and so we're actually looking
into each other's eyes so anyway yeah it
it is the point is it's super realistic
I promise you when I was when I first
did my demo the first time I ever saw it
even knowing that it's 3D I still felt
like I could reach out and like high
five him or like fist bump him he held
that Apple out actually and to my eyes
it looked like he could just drop the
apple he was holding right on the table
in front of me which of course meant
that I looked stupid from this angle
because I'm just reaching out at nothing
but we got a bunch of reactions from
some other Studio team members who got
to join me for this demo I'll link a
video that has some of their reactions
below we should definitely check that
out so it was really only the like
slight glitching a little bit of edges
and fading and stuff like that that kept
out of uncanny valley territory like
obviously the eye contact is one thing
and the 3d effect even it had spatial
audio so if I leaned over here it would
sound like more audio came into one of
your ears and that was responsive but
you know things like in between the
fingers or like the edges of certain
Fabrics or my hair especially some of
that stuff could kind of break it a
little bit and you could tell but
honestly I wasn't thinking about that at
all so you might be thinking kind of the
same thing I was after I finished this
demo which is
okay this is super cool but what is this
for like what is this sort of a tech
demo actually useful for and the answer
is
we don't really know yet so at this
point in time Google has worked with a
few companies Salesforce wework and
T-Mobile are some examples who are
literally using some of these booths for
meetings basically I guess theoretically
that's better than a zoom call although
it still has its limitations like the
face tracking can only work with one
person at a time which means only one
person can be in the booth at a time to
get their realistic depth effect so
adding another person doesn't work I
think the question will be closer to
being answered when the tech gets even
better like we it's already gone from
the size of a room to the size of like
an easel it could just be the size of a
TV with a backpack on it but this will
get more realistic cheaper simpler and
just better but you know here's the
thing I actually don't know that regular
people
will actually want this like hear me out
if I know anything about bleeding edge
Tech which I've tried a lot of it's that
regular people the masses are not very
fast to pay extra for higher Fidelity
like better quality so the the cutoff
for acceptable quality is surprisingly
low for the masses like think about it
audio quality I don't know streaming on
Spotify over Bluetooth seems to be good
enough for most people airpods are the
most popular headphones in the world you
think about cameras and how smartphone
cameras are basically good enough for 99
of the
taking pictures of your kids you know so
convenience is King that like that's why
right now FaceTime and zoom
are it's just a square of a flat low-res
video feed on a screen that's fine it's
fine for most people when you turn it
all the way up to project Starline which
is like this incredibly realistic like
you can see micro expressions and
textures and feel like you're in the
room with the person that's over on one
side here and FaceTime and zoom are on
the other side here and this is where
the masses live and this is like
businesses you know getting a booth so
they don't have to fly people out for
lots of meetings overseas but it's still
too expensive and too difficult to get
to for most people but that's just for
now that's just for this version now I'm
really looking forward to keeping an eye
on how this Tech evolves from Google and
even from others who are working on this
whole 3D light field display technology
stuff we've actually seen some
interesting stuff before I actually
tried an Asus laptop not too many weeks
ago that does the same thing it renders
a unique image for each of your eyes and
does head tracking for an incredibly
realistic 3d effect but of course for
that you have to look at a certain file
that was built in a certain model and
work with certain software this was like
rendering real people and just having a
conversation it's crazy it's crazy
I'm gonna thank you for Google for
letting us see this and I'm gonna
hopefully be able to try future versions
when they get finished because this is
wild let me know what you guys think
thanks for watching
catch you in the next one peace
[Music]